[Music]
as we start winding down in 2023 I've
got to say that the year ended up being
much better than I expected you know a
lot of big anime Making Waves for the
past year or two make it clear that the
industry is in good hands moving forward
as we say goodbye to even more of the
titans of the previous decade it is a
tad too early for a decade retrospective
video however so for today's list we're
going over 10 of my favorite action
titles that have debuted in
kicking things off right off the bat is
shanga
Frontier a new kid on the Block shanga
Frontier already got out to a big
reception with its first few episodes
gaming anime AR a dime a dozen and while
I won't pretend that this show is the
best one of them all it does a great job
capturing everyone's attention from the
get-go due to its overall quality and
eye-catching characters and game designs
the animation is awesome and this is a
series whose author did some thorough
research on gaming overall there's an
air of geniuses here and it felt like
the guys behind this ped their all into
it making it a passionate love letter to
gaming and the community that made it
possible and it's a plot with a goofy
start that gets even better as the anime
goes on if you're still sleeping on the
show by the time this video comes out
then come on have the time of your life
shangar Frontier is such an entertaining
show even non- Gamers can enjoy however
those who've been in the world of video
games will find it one of the most fun
rides in 2020
23 here's to a seasonal contemporary
Undead
unluck Undead unluck like shanga
Frontier made some great first
impressions coming into the fall 2023
season I mean I had high hopes for it
entering the season and I'm glad to see
that it got the start that it deserved
all it took was a first episode and a
cool opening sequence to get the anime
Community talking with a compelling
story and what seemed to be David
production putting in a lot of effort in
making a great adaptation Undead unluck
could be the sleeper hit of the year
when it's all said and done the one
thing that I can see from holding this
back from becoming even bigger is the
weird streaming rights thing that also
locked people who watch legally just
like what happened with summertime
render back then but that shouldn't be
enough to stop devoted anime fans from
being able to experience this fun and
exciting story that gives everyone a
slice of everything you'd want from a
jump series wacky turns a events some
top-notch action sequences and a
sprinkling of fan service the showen
fans won't be strangers to make sure to
tune in to Undead unluck when you get
the chance
to Buddy daddies comes in as our next
entry it's being said oh over and over
again and I'm going to say it once more
the timing of Buddy daddies couldn't
have been more intentional the anime
looked like it was aiming to ride on the
high of spy family's Ultra successful
release it's happened before with the
influx of post-apocalyptic violent
monster versus human series back when
Attack on Titan was the hottest thing in
town but I'd say that buddy daddies
eventually carves out a niche for itself
that makes it feel similar to its
counterpart yet very engaging in its own
right I mean for one buddy daddies as a
show feels Compact and engaging as a
story that largely has to do with how
the anime treats some of its themes like
the child rearing aspect and having
decently realistic characters for an
anime in this genre I do think those
elements are pretty strong especially on
the character development front while it
plot isn't exactly groundbreaking it has
a couple of serious moments with gravity
that help balance out the ample time we
have with the comedic Slice of Life it's
easy to pass buddy daddies as riding on
the success of another show but do give
it a try it will provide a different
experience and might just be the one
you're looking for in a child care
anime
[Music]
talk about successful remakes we have
kenin 2023 up
[Music]
next similar yet different takes on a
whole different meaning when it's kenh
in 2023 a remake of a '90s classic
that's managed to give both new Watchers
and longtime fans something to look
forward to what the 20 23 remake does is
take the same story from the old Kenshin
and give it a modern retouch featuring
way better visuals and a story that
follows the manga more closely what it
means is that it's an anime that delves
more into the drama and the serious mood
that the original manga's going for not
that the source material is devoid of
comedy and light-hearted moments though
kenshin's not that kind of show
definitely as someone who's loved the
'90s version of the anime does make me
feel a bit longing the overall Pepe
feeling of the original both in the
legendary opening and the reaction faces
just isn't quite there anymore and in
place of it a more retrospective and
somber atmosphere that doesn't mean it's
bad however it just means that this is a
nice retread into familiar territory for
fans I don't quite mind the change as
much it still got the reflective story
in the nice battle scenes down pat after
[Music]
all mashall is also making quite a name
for
itself
it seems that there's always a market
for parody anime one which takes some
familiar tropes and then turns them up
to the point of self-awareness and over
the toop comedy that's mashall in a
nutshell looking at it it's easy to go
on a tear and have fun playing a game of
who's who with uh everything Mash
himself reminds me of Sy and it's very
obvious that the whole setting is
inspired by Harry Potter and while
something like seven spell blades draws
little attention to it Mash's overall
toe makes the whole knockoff aspect all
the more obvious but when it comes to
execution Marshall has that part done
amazingly the scenes and the twists are
just about what you'd expect from a show
like this and while the characters
aren't unique they all play their roles
perfectly for the setting if you want
comedy some insane fights or simply
something to remind you of the good old
days of one punch man or psyche K
mashall could satisfy your Cravings one
way or the
[Music]
other with that we've red at the halfway
point on our list quite a lot of action
anime to go but if you've been enjoying
the content so far make sure to hit that
like button and subscribe to the
channel up next we have try gun
[Music]
stampede kenin isn't the only 2023
remake of a beloved classic much earlier
this year we had that modern take on
triun which ended up being quite similar
to Kenshin in making something similar
to the old product yet different in both
subtle and drastic ways and that's not
talking about the overall design and
feel of trun with the decision to go CG
triun Stampede reintroduces original
fans to the cast and the world they're
familiar with but with a shift in toneal
focus to emphasize more on Vash the
character itself his Origins and his
relationship with the people around him
are given a bit more focus and opens up
a rather New Perspective that I'm sure
new fans and returning ones are actually
going to appreciate that's not to say
that the anime has turned all
introspective and carries with it a bog
down Pace at just 12 episodes this show
remains pretty compact it gets to the
point rather quickly and it sprinkles
all those gripping moments with action
sequences that were rendered pretty well
CG considered vintage anime has always
been an attractive Target for remakes
and I think that 2023 has been a decent
year for them as far as action titles
go zom 100 also makes it to the
list this one sure takes me back to the
zombie craze of the 2010 are zombies
cool again well not exactly but Z 100
wasted little time setting the anime
world on fire no adding a premise and a
main character more relatable to the
weary fresh GRS and youth of today
doesn't exactly make zom 100 a unique
zombie apocalypse story by a substantial
amount who cares about being original
when you can stand out in other aspects
you know like having movie quality art
and animation from the get-go and a very
expressive and charismatic cast of main
characters there's impeccable Chemistry
Between members of the main group and
individually they feel very loud and fun
in their own ways all that came together
to push the bar on what already started
a pretty enjoyable ride through the
zombie lad in Japan s 100 is a solid
watch definitely deserving to be one of
the best of 2023 it's just unfortunate
that it's a victim of production
problems here and there but with what we
have right now it's still a worthwhile
watch why don't you check out the source
material while you're at it to it's
nothing too original but as I said with
mashall a while ago the execution and
seeing the characters in action make it
a great
watch hell's Paradise takes you on an
adventure to
remember
if you think the bright lights in the
overall celebratory mood of zom 100
aren't to your liking mappa hell's
Paradise can be a pretty good
alternative carrying the same amazing
animation that Z 100 had this anime
takes you to a treacherous Island of
Adventure hell's Paradise isn't as Grim
as the title or the art might actually
suggest an apt comparison for me would
be Doro from the previous decade which
also came from the same Studio there's
the whole historical setting and all and
it Blends the traditional set of up with
the mystical Allure of the supernatural
the fights in Hell's Paradise are
action-packed and brutal and it really
gets you pumped on the music hits the
action sequences are the best part of
the anime but it's also no slouch when
you consider character building and
giving us some meaningful questions to
ponder upon hell's Paradise is
criminally underrated in my opinion it
doesn't have as much of a loud presence
as some of the big titles of the past
year or so but it does deserve some love
it's no chainsaw man in terms of hype I
can say that but among mappa recent
works I find this to be a very easy
anime to recommend to someone getting
into the medium while looking for
thrilling action adventure
[Music]
anime if we're talking underrated how
about Blades of the
Guardians
oh hell's Paradise may be underrated but
I practically see no one talking about
Blades of the Guardians Chinese anime
don't have public marketing to the
mainstream at all and they're completely
overshadowed by even the moderate hits
of the Season I'm not suggesting that
all of them are great or that the best
of them are better than the big hits
from Japan but I think it's also good if
I can share some of them with you after
all we got a Showcase of insanely good
fight animation and action sequences
from old hits like white cat Legend and
a lot of good things can be said about
Blades of the Guardians Blades of the
Guardians has a simple premise with a
historical backdrop but there's
something gripping in the show that
would make you want to keep watching it
it could be the characters or the way
the story moves on and develops at a
good Pace it allows you to settle into
the world while feeling the mistakes and
the dangers of its era in history it
didn't take too long for me to be hooked
and immersed in this anime so you should
give it a shot and see for yourself
too lastly we have Heavenly
delusion
remember to the new world or promis
Neverland well here's a similar title
and I think it surpassed all
expectations and became my favorite
amongst the new action anime from 2023
integrating good World building and
engaging Mysteries into an action title
turns out to be quite a decent formula
for Success who would have thought eh
and it helps that there's this uncanny
atmosphere to keep the viewers on edge
perfectly contemplating the more mature
themes the anime has for the audience
it's not something made to be a
mainstream hit like the big action
titles are but it does more than well
enough for itself I'd say heavenly
delusion does have rather risque a
Content that might shock viewers but it
remains one of the best in 20123 with
enough action and an interesting world
one filled with a sense of mystery it
showcases the potential of action anime
it's not all about the breathtaking
animation and Loud Showcases of power
after all I get the appeal of hype but
there's a lot more to anime action than
those and Heavenly delusion more than
proves
it I'm also curious to know what the
best of 2023 looks like to you so don't
hesitate to share those as well this has
been a pretty fun list to make and I
hope you can check out the channel to
hear my thoughts on other topics or see
how well my preseason takes have aged
now that we start to say goodbye to the
year 2023 thanks for watching the video
and I hope to see you next time